uh okay so uh it's it's our great
pleasure today to have him in kojogan
from frankfurt and he will talk to us
about uh inference and random factor
graphs so please go ahead
right thank you so i would like to share
with you some of my
recent and recent dish ideas and results
about
inference problems on random factorgrass
and as you can see from the slide
it's joint work with a lot of people
that i've had the pleasure to
work with over the last couple of years
and um so actually this problem or
this family of problems goes back quite
a long time
um for example the
yeah a lot of problems on random graphs
a lot of optimization and inference
problems were studied already
in the 80s and 90s for example there's
some very important work by ravi popana
from 1987
about the planted bisection model so
what you would do is you would take
a set of vertices a large set of
vertices and partition the vertices into
two classes red and blue and then insert
edges
randomly so that edges between vertices
of the same color are preferred
and then your objective would be to find
the optimal bisection in this model the
bisection that cuts the least number of
um
edges also there's a very well-known
work by
uh alon and kahana from 1997 about
the planted coloring problem so here
what you would do is you would
take a set of vertices assign them
random colors
and then create a sparse random graph on
this vertex set
such that the colors that you pre
defined or prescribed for the vertices
are the proper
coloring of the resulting random graph
and then your objective would be to i
mean given just the graph to find
any cue coloring of this graph
and also of course there's the notorious
planted clique problem
where you take a uniformly random graph
gm one half
and then single out a number of vertices
and turn them into a clique and
the problem here would be to either
outright identify the click either put
your finger on where the click is
or simply just distinguish the random
graph with the planted clique from
a purely random graph and in a purely
random graph obviously you would have
a maximum click of order log n
typically but interesting enough in the
planted model we can't
do much better than actually identifying
the clique the planet click once its
size is as large as about square root n
and this result with the square root n
order was already obtained by
orlon kravilevich and suderkoff in 1998
and all of these papers were actually
very influential and
let me say up front that there's a vast
literature on this family of problems
and i'm going to inevitably have to
disappoint some of my
friends on co and colleagues by not
mentioning their
favorite uh references on the other hand
i think
so i'm going to lose some favor and lose
some friends maybe by giving this talk
on the other hand i believe that as
people give more talks on the subject
they also lose friends
so if you rescale by the
decreasing partition function my luck
will improve over time
again uh anyway so let me just rumble on
um in the 90s and early 2000s the
perspective on these problems was a bit
different than it is now
at the time we had some um upcoming
inapproximability results people for
example were very very
um yeah interested in approximation
algorithms
and they were kind of disappointed to
learn that for example
you can't um approximate
the clique problem well or the chromatic
number
and um so these random graph problems
were seen
as as a way out to some extent so
even though you cannot really hope to
gauge algorithms meaningfully by
looking at the approximation ratios they
obtain maybe at least you can use these
random models to benchmark mark
algorithms to say this algorithm is
better than the other
or this this technique this algorithmic
technique works because
it does something clever on a random
graph or that sort of result
and also people were interested in these
models in order to
study heuristic methods for example
the elon kahale algorithm was based on
spectral methods which are
very successful in many applications
and alon and kahala to some extent uh
try to
find an explanation why these work in
practice
and in fact this work has had a lot of
impact so
many papers went on and used similar
techniques
in the context of other problems and
finally
one other motivation was to foster new
algorithmic ideas for example bobana's
work was
one of the seminal works where
semi-definite programming was used
and in the context of such a graph
optimization problems even before the
breakthrough
governs williamson contribution
of course these days we come from a
different perspective
our interest is probably mostly in
statistics
and learning and so we come from the
viewpoint of
inference from noisy observations if we
are presented with noisy data
what can we learn about
the object of interest effectively and
one interesting
way of looking at it that i learned from
a paper by
lenka and florent is the so-called
teacher student model
in this model you imagine a teacher
that is supposed to train a student by
conveying a certain ground truth to the
student
and the teacher finds themselves unable
to just convey the ground truth verbatim
and instead presents the students with a
number of
noisy examples that are generated on the
basis of the ground truth
and depending on the quality of the
teachers some of the examples might be
very
might contain valuable information other
might others might be misleading
so the student faces the problem of
figuring out on the basis of the
examples that they are presented
what the ground truth was or at least to
recover as much of the
ground truth as possible so
the student cannot get their hands
directly on
the information that the teacher tries
to convey
but instead receives some noisy data and
is supposed to
learn the hidden information
somewhat indirectly and a good model
a good example of such a model is the
stochastic block model that has received
a lot of attention in recent years
this is a bit similar to the planted
coloring model of
alon and kahale in that we begin by
choosing colors for the vertices
so we fix maybe a number q maybe three
of colors
and we in the first step we simply draw
a color for each vertex
independently and in the second step so
this would be the
so this coloring would be the ground
truth that the teacher effectively tries
to convey
and in the second step what we would do
is we would create a
random graph um where the probability
that two vertices are connected by
an edge depends on whether they share
the same color
under this coloring sigma star from
the first step and there's two different
versions of this model in the
disassortative version we would
discourage monochromatic edges kind of
like in the
along kahala coloring model where we
outright forbid them
and in the assortative model we would
actually encourage
monochromatic edges
and um so in most of the talk i'm going
to focus on the disassortative
version where we create a graph like
like this here where um effectively on
the diagonal
blocks of the adjacency matrix we expect
the graph to be a bit sparser than on
the off diagonal
pieces and of course now
in this model the question would be
can we somehow detect the ground truth
from
the observations that we make and
naturally the larger the number of edges
the more the graph is going to reveal
about
the ground truth so there's a trade-off
here between
the parameter beta and the number of
edges that we are going to need in order
to
discover sigma star so
in the disassortative case the larger
beta and
the larger the number of edges
the easier it should be to recover or at
least partially
recover sigma star
another example is low density generator
matrix codes
um in this case i mean this is an
example from coding theory and it's
maybe not surprising that
coding theory would come up in this
context in this case
the ground truth is simply a sequence of
n
bits and
we are not shown this sequence of n bits
verbatim but instead
what the teacher does is they form a
code word by simply multiplying this
message vector sigma star with the
generator matrix
of a code and then the resulting code
word
gets sent across a noisy channel and
our job as a student is to recover the
original message sigma star
from the noisy observation that we
receive namely
the well we received the code word but
not actually the code word but the
codeword plus
some noise vector that was introduced by
the channel and of course the noisier
the channel the harder it will be to
recover sigma star and um
also the i mean the the larger the
matrix a the taller
this code word y becomes the more rows
of the matrix a has the easier it should
be in principle
to recover the ground truth
um yet another example that i like very
much is group testing
in group testing um there's a large
population
and um i mean this seemed a bit
outlandish at the time when we started
working on this but
imagine that a new virus befalls mankind
and all of a sudden it spreads and you
have the problem of
detecting the infected individuals
within your population so um
there's a large population a small
fraction of it hopefully are
infected with the virus and in order to
economize test resources we do not just
test
every person individually every person
separately
but we conduct pooled tests where
several people
are grouped into
one test and the test result will come
back
positive if and only if one of the
participants of that test group are
infected
one or more participants are affected
and then the
we receive these pooled test results and
the objective would be to learn from
these pooled results
who the infected individuals would be
and so maybe superficially all of these
problems look very different
and they may seem to require
separate treatment but actually there's
a common core to them
there's a common way of looking at them
um
which is a kind of yeah
it's a very powerful formalism that
might look a bit scary at first
but it's not so hard after all and this
formalism
is the formalism of random factor graphs
it's a bit indirect but there's merits
to looking at
it in this slightly indirect manner
so instead of in a straightforward
fashion defining
an inference problem what we are going
to do is we are going to
first put the omelette on the other side
and define
another model for example in the case of
the stochastic block model
the null model would be simply just the
addition rainy random graph so just a
purely random graph with no
planted coloring no hidden structure
whatsoever you just
throw in a bunch of random matches
um and in general for
these these general models not just the
stochastic block model but also the
error correcting codes and the group
testing
and whatnot there's a generic way of
doing it
so we would
create namely what we would do is you
will create a random factor graph
a factor graph has two types of vertices
on the one side
variable nodes x1 up to xn
and these variable nodes are supposed to
represent the entries of the ground
truth vector
so for example in the group testing
problem these would be the patients
in the stochastic block model these
would be
the vertices or the colors of the
vertices that we try
to learn and these variable nodes range
over some finite domain omega
for example the colors in the stochastic
block model
and they are represented by these round
vertices up here
in addition we have factor nodes a1 up
to am that represent
the interactions or the observations
that we make about
these variable nodes and each of these
factor nodes comes with a weight
function
this weight function takes as input the
spins or the values assigned to the
adjacent
variables and spits out a
non-negative weight how much
effectively this corresponding factor
nodes
factor node likes that value combination
and in this null model we simply just
connect
these nodes and the variable nodes
randomly
these weight functions can be random as
well so they need not be the same for
all the different
check nodes also the degrees of the
check nodes need not be the same
we would we would assume that there are
some prior distribution of these weight
functions maybe
and um as for the graph structure itself
you could either create a bipartite
graph for example of a
rainy type or you could create a graph
with given degrees or
i mean any other natural random graph
model that you could
come up with perhaps the important thing
about this null model is that it doesn't
have any particular structure it's just
more or less purely random there might
be some restrictions like degrees and so
on
but as yet there's no particular
assignment for the variables that we
have in mind
based on just this information namely
the weight functions
essentially just the weight functions we
can then define the probability
distribution for this
dial model on assignments
so for any assignment or configuration
any value assignment of vn variables
we would define the corresponding weight
simply as
the product on all the individual factor
nodes of
the weight that that factor node assigns
to the
values under this assignment and
this weight i mean this total weight
then naturally defines a probability
distribution that we say the probability
that
a specific configuration comes up is
proportional
to its overall weight and
there's a normalization required of
course and this normalization
quantity is what we call the partition
function
uh right so any questions up to this
point
i think i can somehow
maybe
yeah i can see the chat so if you have
any questions if i'm going too quickly
or
something just type in the chat i think
i can
yeah i can see it now
okay otherwise i'll just uh plow ahead
okay so we have this null model where we
simply just basically
link up variables and factor notes
randomly and choose weight functions for
the different
factor nodes and so the interesting
thing is that
by looking at it in the right way we
actually obtain
a inference problem from this model
automatically
namely what we can do is we can define
or introduce size bias distributions on
graphs and on assignments
and to introduce the size biased
distribution on grass what we do is we
simply say well the probability that
under this bias distribution a specific
graph comes up
is proportional to the partition
function of that graph
so the larger the partition function
the more likely it is for a specific
graph to
come up and
similarly for the assignments for the
configurations we would say
the larger the average weight of a
specific configuration
the more likely we are to actually
choose that
configuration so the weight of so the
probability of a configuration is
proportional to its
average weight and also we can put these
two things together these two ideas
together
and define the planted model for a
specific
configuration by saying that we draw a
graph
with a probability that is proportional
to
the weight of that particular
configuration
okay so this way we already defined
a planted model and we have these two
size biased distribution distributions
and um we can now generically define
this t-shirt student scheme
the teacher would go ahead and choose a
ground truth sigma star
from the size buyer's distribution on
assignments in most interesting cases
this will basically be
the uniform distribution on assignments
there could be other cases where you
might
want to where implicitly maybe this
construction prescribes
a specific weight a specific hemming
weight on
one vectors or something but in most
cases this will basically be
the uniform distribution and
subsequently the set of examples the set
of observations
that the teacher produces is
encoded by a random factor graph drawn
from the
corresponding planted model so the
teacher
chooses first the ground truth sigma
star and then produces the examples for
the students which are
encoded in this random factor graph
i mean can i ask a question by all means
so i should know this already by reading
your papers but so
going for instance to the stochastic
block model uh and you just said
don't worry it's it's basically the
uniform
uh distribution but so for instance in
the
assortative stochastic block model
um i take it that this distribution
would be a little bit closer to having
uh
sorry no a little bit farther from
having
equal size groups then the unit then the
uniform distribution
that's why because we would we would
gain from the overall probability as you
say the average weight from having
more potential monochromatic edges
so so in order to encode the assortative
model you would have to
take into account the non edges for
example
or you would have to expressly forbid
um assignments that are
that are very unbalanced and
and putting it differently i guess this
size biased prior if you will on sigma
i guess it has the property that if i
choose from that
generate a planted graph from that and
then
infer sigma that the distribution on
sigma is then a fixed point under that
process of generation and then inferring
it
whereas the uniform distribution on uh
labelings or colorings or whatever would
not in fact be
exactly that's right yeah okay yeah so
that's that's one reason why i don't
like the assortedness model so much
well okay so we could have said the same
thing about the disrotative model making
it a bit
closer to reducing the fluctuations in
the
the color class sizes that's right but
in that case you would end up with
something that is at least contiguous to
the right distribution
yeah exactly so so that's a good point
um but there's
i mean there's always ways of fixing
this
by introducing either non-edges or some
other
i mean or for example you could nudge it
to some particular hemming weight by
having suitably chosen external fields
okay so uh right
so coming back to the teacher so they
just choose this ground truth sigma star
and then produce the examples
and then the student is presented a set
of examples
and um their job is to basically
get back at sigma star from these
examples
and um so the overall distribution that
the student faces
is simply just the this related
distribution here
from the first line so basically
um what we are looking at here is we
have to figure out
the posterior distribution of sigma star
that's the problem that the student has
in order to get back at the ground truth
um they would have to um
get a handle on the on the posterior of
sigma star
and um so the nice feature about this
posterior distribution is now
something that i call the nishimori
identity
which is specifically that the posterior
of sigma star is
nothing but the boltzmann distribution
so
in other words the student's problem is
to
get a handle on the boltzmann
distribution of
this planted random graph g star
and in particular a quantity that is
of fundamental interest in this context
is the mutual information
which is the information theoretic
potential that basically tells you how
much you can learn about the ground
truth
and this quantity is up to a constant
related
to the expectation of the logarithm of
the partition function
so the amount of data that we can learn
about the ground truth
is effectively encoded in the partition
function in these models
so having seen this general framework
which may look
a bit yeah a bit abstract and a bit
scary
let's see how we can uh get the peculiar
models or the
models that i showed in the beginning um
from this
so for example the this disassortative
stochastic block model we would get
by saying well my variable nodes are
just
the vertices of my graph i've got q
colors at my
disposal and i have a single
weight function which takes as input two
colors
and says the weight is e to the minus
beta
if the colors are the same and one if
they are
distinct and the nine model in this case
would just be the
address really random graph so if you
follow the dots that i outlined about
this
abstract factor graph model and
you just basically yeah run this
procedure you will
arrive at the stochastic block model
um the lg gm code you can also get from
this construction in a valley
yeah it's a no-brainer basically
what you do is you um take your n
variables you
yeah it's convenient to encode the
boolean or the bit zero one by
plus minus ones um and you have these
factor nodes that correspond to the
parity checks
of your error correcting code in coding
theory in particular it's
actually a good idea normally to be a
bit diligent about the choices of the
degrees
so you can sometimes get some mileage
out of choosing
the degree sequences on both the
variable side
and on the factor node side
diligently and so you can then
basically i mean so for example one
construction that that is
very convenient is if you prescribe
distributions on the variable node side
and on the factory outside
and then draw iid samples from these
distributions
and then you generate a random bipartite
graph
with these particular degrees and these
weight functions down here
encode both the parity checks and the
noise level
of your channel and also group testing
you can encode easily on the one side
you have the variables which represent
the patients on the other side you have
the
factor notes which represent the checks
and the weight functions basically just
indicate whether the
test result is compatible with the
infection status that you surmise for
the different patients
um so the advantage of having this
unified framework is
well that we can actually prove things
about it
and that we can obviously then
just use this general result to get some
information about
particular problems of interest
so in particular um again
on the basis of or again on the basis of
physics predictions
um there's a generic physics approach to
these problems called
the cavity method and the cavity method
tells you how you for example can
compute
the mutual information in these problems
so how can we compute
this mutual information potential that
tells us how much about the ground truth
we can recover from the
observations and another question that
comes up and
that can be answered heuristically in
this context is whether there's an
information theoretic threshold
in other words whether there's some
threshold some signal to noise ratio
effectively from where on you can start
um non-trivial inference if you are
given
infinite computational resources so it's
at some point from where you can
in principle learn the ground truth at
least partially from the data that you
observe
and of course the next question would be
can you actually perform this task
efficiently is there some efficient
algorithm for
learning or getting a part of the ground
truth back from the
noisy data and um
so like i said the cavity method is
based on the belief propagation
message passing scheme um one important
hypothesis
is that in these inference problems you
don't have
complicated long-range correlations
namely that the posterior distribution
the boltzmann distribution effectively
is what we call replica
symmetric this means that in a
cartoon-like fashion it either looks
like this that you
that the support of your boltzmann
distribution is one big blob
which indicates that you have too little
information you can't do anything
you simply have not enough data to learn
the ground truth
the second possibility is that it looks
like this that your
measure decomposes into an abundance of
little islands um one of these islands
um is inhabited by the ground truth of
your
problem but unfortunately you don't know
which so
in the absence of a lucky guess you
cannot get back at the ground truth in
this scenario
and the last possibility is that
effectively
basically maybe up to trivial symmetries
there's just one blob
in your measure and
this one little blob houses the ground
truth so it should be easy to get back
at it
and generically in replica symmetric
problems
the physics recipe for dealing with them
would be
the belief propagation message passing
scheme
a belief propagation basically
associates two probability distributions
with each edge of your factor graph
these are probability distributions on
the set of colors for example in the
stochastic block model and generally on
the set of values that your variables
can
take and
the belief propagation formalism
sets out a bunch of equations that these
variables these messages are supposed to
satisfy and
the messages are essentially sufficient
to get a full picture of what your
boltzmann distribution
looks like so the heuristic would be to
basically
try and find solutions to these fixed
point equations here
and then follow the belief propagation
formalism that you
may have heard about for example in the
context of three factor graphs um
to basically follow this formalism to
get the information about the model
that you need
and so maybe we are in luck and maybe
there's not so many fixed points
to these equations many not maybe not so
many solutions to these equations
maybe we can somehow find them classify
them and
get the information out that we want
in particular the messages contain the
information
necessary to compute the mutual
information in this model
namely there's a formula called the beta
free energy that tells you
how you can calculate your partition
function
and what you should do is basically you
should find the fixed point of belief
propagation that maximizes
the beta-free energy so this
heuristic physics approach called the
cavity method basically
reduces your problem to
the problem of finding the belief
propagation
fixed point that maximizes this function
and in fact there's there's one more
step that you can take
namely this belief propagation
the system of equations here refers to a
particular factor graph now actually our
factor graphs are random
and sparse which means that locally they
are described by some sort of a golden
watson tree
so you could instead of running belief
propagation on the actual factor graph
you might as well replace the factor
graph
by the golden watson tree that mimics
the local structure of your graph
and then work in terms of
not the messages themselves but in terms
of the distribution of messages that you
would obtain on this gordon watson tree
if you were to kind of
unravel this gordon watson tree layer
after layer
and um so this results in a dis
in a probability distribution on
messages in other words
in a probability distribution on
probability distributions
on values for your variables
and when you do this step of abstraction
what happens with the beta free energy
is that it turns into a functional
on the space of probability measures on
messages anyway this is all worked out
beautifully in this article
by lenka and floron from 2016
and um this
theorem here turns these ideas into
rigorous maths to a large extent on
a white class of models it's not totally
universal
there's a bunch of interesting models
that are not covered by this
um and so writing down the assumptions
to this theorem
is a bit unpleasant so um
i will not do it i will just promise you
that
there's some symmetry assumptions
and some mild assumptions on the degrees
of your random factor graph model
that suffice to turn these physics
predictions into
the mathematical theorem at least at
least as far as the
mutual information is concerned the
symmetry assumptions basically postulate
that there must be a trivial fixed point
to your belief propagation recurrence
for example
in the stochastic block model this would
be the fixed point where
all the messages are the uniform
distribution or colors
in other words if you know nothing then
this should be
a fixed point to your belief propagation
equations in the error
in the error correcting codes for
example the
symmetry assumption would be satisfied
in the sense that
um all the messages uniform meaning that
i don't know any bit would
be again a fixed point to your belief
propagation
uh recurrence and there's also a sort of
convexity condition
that is satisfied by the disassortative
stochastic block model
but not by the assortative version of
the stochastic block model that is
needed to make this work
nonetheless it's kind of yeah it's it's
a step in the good direction i would say
it's not
it doesn't cover everything but um it
provides a
yeah somewhat comprehensive
justification of these
cavity method predictions and it seems
fair to say that the techniques probably
carry over to
a bunch of other problems that are not
formally covered by
uh the result as such um
so for the address ready model we did
this with lenka and four and will
perkins a few years ago
and more recently um some of my
students max uh aunt klim wrote philip
lloyd
um my postdoc muller matthias
from munich and costa pranagyatu did it
for more general models with
prescribed degrees for example
uh so we can obviously now that we have
this abstract result
we can plug in specific models for
example
this result here verifies the mutual
information
for the disassortative stochastic block
model
the formula comes out as a variational
problem so you have this
functional here the beta free energy
functional on the space of
probability measures on a simplex
and so in order to solve this problem
here
you are supposed to find the probability
measure on the simplex
that maximizes this functional here
of course this is a bit complicated um
in fact it's probably awfully
complicated if you try to solve it
but it matches the physics prediction
and at least it proves that
these heuristic techniques actually get
to the bottom of the problem
so um it's pretty complicated but it's
not more complicated than
uh predicted by the physics methods
and uh okay at least this replica
symmetric so in other words you have
you have yeah you have at least
um some idea
um i mean what level of complexity you
are facing
uh right
so we can get the so what goes wrong in
the
um assortative model so we can actually
get the assortative model into our
framework
but what happens is that there's
a somewhat inconvenient convexity
assumption
that is needed for this general result
and that is simply violated by the
assortative stochastic block model um
we can get one direction out of our
results so one direction you can get
namely you can get the
lower bound on the information
theoretical threshold but not the upper
bound
right so there's a corollary about the
information theory threshold in the
stochastic block model
for two communities this was already
known for example by
this was already known thanks to muscle
neiman and sly
and there were bounds on more than two
communities
and these results actually um cover both
the assortative and the
this assorted these results come about
the assortative and the disalterative
version
um then we have a result about low
density generator matrix codes
so again this is just basically applying
the general result
to a specific model um
and again we obtain a result that
matches the predictions from physics and
actually proves a conjecture of
montanari from 2005
about the ldgm codes
yeah so i'm not going to say much about
the proof but basically
it's pretty complicated at least for
this general result
but not because there's complicated
computations
so the proof is not really heavy on
computations
it's fairly conceptual in the sense that
we use
an abstract tool called the pinning
lemma in order to
verify this prediction that the
boltzmann distribution is replica
symmetric
and then we use two again fairly
conceptual fairly abstract tools that
are close to
um close and spirit to the physics
calculations namely the eisenmann sims
star scheme
and the interpolation method and the
iceman sim star scheme is actually
very very close to the um
physics way of thinking about these
problems which is why i like it a lot
it gets a bit subtle because um the
coupling arguments required by this
technique
get pretty intricate
or pretty delicate but it's it's
conceptually quite close to
the idea of putting the physics
calculations effectively on
on rigorous tracks
uh right
okay so let's move on to algorithms um
right so
i mean a quick question let's yeah let's
do it uh
later here okay um
okay so let's move on to algorithms so
the um
right so again a prediction from our
good friends from physics is that
actually belief propagation should be
the ultimate
inference algorithm and
so in these problems like the stochastic
block model for example there's always
a trivial fixed point um that belief
propagation could run into
namely in the case of the stochastic
block model just the paramagnetic
solution where you
you say well everybody just has the
uniform distribution i don't know
anything
and um so
it is tempting to conjecture and
actually empirically it turns out that
way
that the success of belief propagation
as an inference algorithm depends on
whether this fixed point is
attractive or not and um
so in other words we would assume that
so long as the fixed point the trivial
fixed point is attractive
it will trap belief propagation and
belief propagation will not manage to
home in onto
the non-trivial solution onto
the ground truth effectively and that
would mean that
there might be a dichotomy in these
problems between problems where
the true solution to the information
theoretic potential the true maximizer
of your beta-free energy branches out
continuously from
the trivial fixed point or problems that
appears
somewhere else at a totally different
point
discontinuously and in the latter case
we would assume that maybe
there's a gap between what you can do
algorithmically
and what you can do information
theoretically with infinite
computational resources
and there's actually a way of
trying to formalize this namely a
generalized version of the
question stigma bound that again works
for
all of these factor graph models
generically
and so here's how this works so you
would
for any given weight function you would
introduce an omega by omega matrix a
matrix on
on pairs of spins that kind of works
like a
transition matrix which tells you how
likely it is to transition from spin
omega to spin
omega prime under this particular
weight function and um
given a
yeah exactly and uh
given the uh so joe's answer is actually
spot-on
uh and uh given this
that they are okay given this uh given
these matrices these transition matrices
here
you can then define um a
an operator on the tensor space r omega
tens of
r omega
and um
so
um this i mean if you know about the
original caster stigma this operator is
kind of similar to
describing the broadcasting process that
you would see
in combination with the reverse process
the reverse
i mean the top down process would be the
first component of the tensor and the
bottom up process would be the second
component of this tensor effectively
and um on the basis of this this linear
operator
or in terms of the spectrum of this
linear operator
we can then express the stability of the
belief propagation
fixed point and so this particular
threshold here where you say
i look at the maximum
eigenvalue of this operator in a certain
constraint
space where we throw out some some um
eigenvalues that are
irrelevant to our problem uh then
corresponds to
a generic version of the kesten's legal
bound so
this would be precisely the point where
the trivial
belief propagation solution becomes
unstable so
yeah it would be tempting to conjecture
that this is somehow related
to the performance of belief propagation
as
an inference algorithm and so in fact if
we
specialize this to the stochastic block
model
what we see is exactly of course i mean
by kind of by design the
original casting stigm bound and
there's matching algorithms um for this
by rb and sending
even though we don't at this point know
precisely how we propagate or vigorously
how belief propagation
will perform if you look at ldgm codes
it turns out
that in that case this generalized
testosterone bound would be
infinity um so this this matrix here
has has a singularity in other words and
um this is unsurprising because in this
case the algorithmic version of the
problem
is closely related to the k-side
refutation problem
and we don't expect that to be soluble
for any finite um constraint to variable
ratio i guess so uh
an open problem i suppose is that
generally we can algorithmically achieve
this casting stigma bound i mean maybe
there's some conceptual reason
why that should always be possible i
think it would be very interesting to to
see that
and maybe conversely it would be
interesting of course to see
negative results for specific
types of algorithms failing below
or up to this castens decompound
right so again it would be interesting
to refute or corroborate
this hamshire that um you would maybe
get
a hard phase in these inference problems
a hard algorithmic phase
if the cast and stigma bound is
separated from the
information theoretic bound which
normally typically
occurs when this phase transition is
discontinuous when you get
a suddenly get a new fixed point a new
solution to believe propagation pop up
somewhere at a place that is totally
unrelated to
the trivial fixed point so
let me finish by maybe saying a few
words about
group testing which is a problem that i
like a lot
um because it's
um it's actually
i think it might even be useful actually
which would be a
new experience for me i mean working on
something useful
and it's it's at the same time also
quite intriguing so in the group testing
problem at least
in the version that is commonly studied
in the math literature
um the situation is this you have a
population of size n
and within this population a certain
number of
patients a number of individuals enter
the theta
are infected with a disease with a virus
if you like
for some exponent theta between zero and
one so the
so in this particular setup it turns out
that
mathematically the interesting case is
when the number
of infected individuals is sublinear in
the population size
and we conduct group tests
or we want to conduct group tests
with as small a number of
um tests as possible in order to
precisely
identify the infected individuals
and a natural random design would be to
simply have each
individual join an equal number of test
groups
and when you do a little back of the
envelope calculation you discover that
the correct group size is the correct
number of
groups that each individual should join
in order to
extract the maximum amount of
information should be
about this much here so something like m
times log 2 divided by n to the theta
divided by the total number of infected
individuals
and as a result you would discover that
the number of
the total number of patients per
test would be something like n to the
one minus theta times
log 2. and
in this case okay so in this case it
turns out
that if you plot the infection density
theta
on this axis and the obvious
linear factor in front of the number of
tests on this axis
that there is quite a large regime here
this red area
where the problem is information
theoretically infeasible
so in this entire red area here
unfortunately there's nothing you can do
so provably it is not possible to
actually
infer the set of infected
individuals correctly on the other hand
here in this blue area this blue
triangle
if you have in other words enough tests
at your disposal
depending on the infection density
you can in fact solve the problem using
simple greedy algorithms
so in that case there are simple greedy
algorithms that basically boil down to
warning propagation
will solve the problem in polynomial
time
however there remains a yellow area here
where we can prove that the problem is
information theoretically feasible
but at this point we do not know an
efficient algorithm now even though the
group testing problem
doesn't fall under this general theorem
that i presented earlier
we can ask whether maybe something like
a casting stigma bound something like
attractiveness of the trivial fixed
point is going on
in this case and um one of my students
philip actually worked this out a few
days ago
and he discovered that actually there is
some
some sort of fixed point
attractiveness going on in this problem
as well namely
um if you are in this yellow area here
it turns out that again a trivial
solution
to belief propagation would be
attractive and even though the solution
that you would find
in the group testing problem would have
a significant
overlap with the correct set of infected
individuals
for example because you can rest assured
that anyone that
is in a negative test actually is
uninfected
um there's still a still
a trivial fixed point that pops up
amongst the remaining individuals
and that will and the stability of this
fixed point will stop
belief propagation from actually homing
in on the correct
solution on the other hand in the group
testing problem we showed that actually
there is
another solution to the problem there's
another construction another random
factor graph model that you can use in
order to solve the problem
uh precisely um based on the idea of
spatial coupling
so instead of using a plain random
test design like i described in the
beginning
what you would do is you would
superimpose a geometric
ring structure on your test design
partition your tests and individuals
into
compartments that are arranged in a ring
topology
endow the seat the beginning of the ring
with some extra tests so that you can
get a good handle on the beginning and
then work your way from one compartment
to the other diagnosing the
individuals along the ring topology
effectively
and this idea of spatial coupling has of
course been used previously in other
problems like for example ldpc
decoding or compressed sensing also
a variant of compressed sensing called
quantitative
group testing and based on this
idea we can actually make this yellow
area blue
and obtain a group testing algorithm
that
solves the problem completely and indeed
even though we didn't really set out
in the beginning to analyze belief
propagation it turns out
that this group testing algorithm that
we
um came up with is
precisely belief propagation it's
precisely
a variant of belief propagation um
written down in terms of log likelihood
ratios
so in this case we can actually kind of
close the book and say well okay there's
this guest legal kind of behavior
and we can analyze belief propagation on
the spatially coupled
ensemble and prove that it completely
solves
the problem to optimality
okay so that's my last slide uh it's a
short summary
i tried to explain or share my
thoughts on these inference problems um
i hope i didn't overwhelm you with the
different models and this particulars
abstract model
i think there's a few interesting
potentially even practical applications
like maybe
group testing there's some unexpected
applications of these results maybe for
example we can get some results about
the rank of random matrices that on the
face
of the problem don't seem to have
anything to do with
inference at all and i should mention
there's
also an alternative approach to many of
these problems based on the stochastic
interpolation method developed by
um by um
baby and macris over the last couple of
years
thank you very much for your attention
okay thank you so much for the talk um i
guess there were a couple of questions
already that came up during the
right so uh right
so about the pinning lemma um so this
right so um
so this pinning trick is is kind of
acute
idea and it doesn't work on inference
problems alone it actually works on any
measure
so if you take any probability measure
on let's say the hamming cube zero one
to the m
and you draw a random configuration from
it
and then you from this random
configuration you fix a few
bounded number of entries and you
you fix um these entries in your in your
original model so you basically
fix a few randomly chosen variables in
your
original factor graph model to these
particular spin values
it always works it will always produce a
replica symmetric problem it will always
make long-range correlations
go away so that's very funny
um and uh
right so andrea monteneri um observed
this in the particular
in a particular case of error correcting
codes
in 2008 and
then ragavanra and chan
observed something like this in 2012
using
a very short information theoretic proof
and then we somehow
discovered or rediscovered it in our
language in the context of this problem
as well and that's at first glance it
seems pretty
puzzling so you might think uh okay if
that's true then why doesn't this entire
uh idea of replica symmetry breaking
collapse
but it turns out that that it doesn't so
what joe wrote in the chat is part of
the answer
so obviously if you only want to compute
the free energy then
you only care about a constant fraction
of the measure
that's that's certainly correct um
but this would also be correct
in the presence of replica symmetry
breaking
so you might think that you could just
basically steamroll replica symmetry
breaking and
always only work with replica symmetric
problems
but that's not true so the reason is
that if you do this eisenmann simstar
coupling construction
what would happen is that by
adding some structure to your random
factor graph by doing this coupling
argument you would
rescale the distribution that you have
to pin from
so you would then have to go back and
pin from a different distribution
somehow
and that makes it very complicated on
the other hand in these
inference problems this re-weighting
problem
doesn't actually occur because you know
a priori precisely in which way you have
to
do the re-weighting because
that is encoded in this
uh description of the model
oh yeah oh no to go back away so this is
kind of
encoded in this description of the model
already
so
yeah okay so um the next question
so the next question that i can see
[Music]
is when the physics predictions have
been wrong
um
[Music]
yeah okay so uh
it depends on the definition of wrong
so i mean generally they have been
more correct than wrong i would say
overall um there's a few
things that we could put our fingers on
where we could say well
this was maybe a long shot and it didn't
work
so one one prediction that was wrong was
like
was for example about the performance of
message passing algorithms
on random constraint satisfaction
problems
there are sometimes um our good friends
from physics were too optimistic
um but i mean that was a long shot to
begin with and they knew it was a long
shot
another example was another example when
they
might sometimes be wrong is
when these equations these fixed-point
equations have
unexpected solutions so
at some point
somewhere yeah i wrote these fixed point
equations
and sometimes they have a solution that
you wouldn't expect
or that you would think they shouldn't
have
i am am i the only one for whom the
video froze
no you're not for me
i mean can you hear us
i'll try asking in the chat
oh okay there you are my computer just
decided to crash
oh okay it happens
so sometimes you get um a funny solution
that these fixed-point equations
shouldn't have
maybe or you think they shouldn't have
them or
you first think they shouldn't have them
then you think again and then you
discover the solution
and you decide well actually that should
be a solution
um and so that kind of thing can happen
and that
that might lead to wrong predictions so
for example in the case of these matrix
rank
uh problems that that was something that
happened that
um the uh yeah
i mean the prediction just makes missed
a fixed point
so yeah but but conceptually they've
been
surprisingly accurate i would say
um i know but i guess there's other
people also in the audience that could
comment on this
and uh chris did you have a question as
well
oh he answered it thank you oh okay
are there other questions
maybe while people are collecting their
thoughts i i had a quick question which
was just
uh this variational problem over pi for
the the beta free energy
are there some natural conditions that
help you
choose the critical point
right so i would actually assume
so i don't know so an interesting thing
that
uh an interesting question i think is
whether we can narrow down
um the correct solution
and i think in fact we can so in all the
problems
that i've worked on a bit more closely
um what happened was that the correct
solution was one of two things
um either the uniform distribution just
the trivial solution
or the solution that you would get if
you were to start from the ground truth
itself
and so
for example and so obviously the
uh yeah in some cases there's evidence
that this is actually
the only two possibilities
and of course it would be nice to prove
that because that would eliminate this
um crazy variational problem or at least
maybe not eliminate it but
at least turn it into something that you
could manage on a computer
yeah uh-huh and do you do you know for
example if uh
if in general the the supervisor is is
always
an attractive fixed point it should be
the case
it should probably be the case um
unless you're looking at some crazy
critical values maybe
oh okay yeah i i would think so but i
we don't have a proof of it
actually there are some funny cases so
for example one case that is that is
really funny
is when you look yeah
so this might be a counter could be a
counter x
actually no so it's probably not a
counter example but one one case that is
very peculiar is
if you take a binomial random matrix
so an n by n matrix every over f2
every entry is one with probability d
over n
and so what happens in that case is that
you get
two maximizers at the same height
so you get two equivalent maximizers
and if you actually sample such a random
matrix with
probability half the one maximizer is
correct
and probability half is the other
maximizer
i see but then each of those would be an
attractive fixed point
each of them would be attractive but you
have two attractive
guys that are precisely competing on the
same footing
i think so sorry just to clarify
you're not saying that the ground truth
is an attractive fixed point you mean
that if you use the grand truth as an
initial condition
you reach an attractive fixed point so
you would still have to
do some dynamics from that point to see
where you end up right
but the conjecture for instance would be
that wherever you do end up
is among other things a uh
an upper bound on the
overlap you can achieve indeed that it
would equal the overlap achieved
information theoretically right i mean
it's
it's it would be interesting to
investigate whether you can
ever get anything else then i mean apart
from maybe
critical values if you can never get
anything else but
either the trivial solution
or whatever you are getting when you
start from the ground truth
i mean i'm not aware of any specimen
where you would
end up with something else but like i
said i mean this is uh
we are talking about an infinite
dimensional space so there could be a
lot of things
hiding here or that there's a lot of
spaces to hide
uh yeah
but uh questions yeah
oh yeah um just to follow up on your
answer to my question so i think you
said that the
uh performance of message passing on
random csps that was one case for
business for too optimistic
um no particular reference for this uh
result or
uh yeah so there's there's a paper of
mine from
a few years back um about belief
propagation on random cases
[Music]
so
[Music]
yeah 2017
and so so there were competing
predictions about the performance of
belief propagation guided decimation for
finding random
for finding solutions in random cases
and
it's a bit unfair so because
i i i like physicists because they they
they like to i mean they make progress
they are sometimes wrong and sometimes
they
change their minds and i think that
should be allowed
so i i like people that change their
minds
and um so in this case there was one
prediction which was
quite wrong and then
some of the some of the authors changed
their mind and the prediction was
actually correct
so it's
it's complicated i mean so in
phys so chris might correct me but my my
slant on the matter is that in physics
truth is a function of space-time
in physics it's considered just it's
better to say something wrong than to
say nothing at all
but i think part of the subtlety right
is that from outside physics produces a
bunch of different kinds of results some
of them might be numerical
experiments on large but finite
instances
which could produce incorrect
extrapolations to infinity
then there are things like uh you know
analysis of message passing which also
uses
numerics like population dynamics
where you're not you're not looking at
in theory you're in you're now analyzing
infinite
random problems but you're using some
finite precision for
figuring out this uh you know this
variational problem this
fixed point distribution of messages and
conversions can be very tricky to assess
numerically there
and that can sometimes get something
that which is
wrong but it might be right that
whatever that fixed point is
what would give the right prediction if
we could compute it so there's sort of
different ontological statuses of
different quote unquote
physics predictions that's right
so another example that things let's say
evolved over time is
probably the hardcore model right
and and some other cases where people
were not quite certain
what the correct level of replica
symmetry breaking should be
so i think hypergraph coloring also
changed status at some point
on that count i mean if
if i may ask you didn't mention hatred
you're you're
[Music]
sorry right yes so there was another
yeah another point for debate i guess
right so his work was on survey
propagation
that's right uh and it i believe it
stopped at the same value where your
analysis of the belief propagation
stopped right
it's it it was a bit higher so he
he got this extra k factor yeah but
yeah but um let's say
um yeah so maybe maybe some
physicists expressed opinions about
survey propagation that were slightly
more upbeat
than the result that he
believed he got
to i mean i hope i hatched my bets
sufficiently
i think you did there's there's a paper
i think 2016
on on something called backtracking
survey propagation right yes
not sure anybody analyzed backtracking
version of it
but the there it's pretty sort of solid
with
conjecture that it should work up to the
condensation threshold
but it's like i said i mean this this
entire realm of
algorithms i mean
i'm kind of tasked to capacity when i
try to understand replica symmetric
problems
but if you try to look at something that
has replica symmetry breaking and then
go ahead
and run an algorithm on it and then set
one variable at a time
i mean that yeah seems like a pretty
dear shot to me
so it's i think it's genuinely just very
difficult to
to say anything about it and
but i think in terms of these inference
problems we are on
on safer ground in some sense so they
are mathematically a lot easier than
problems that have
replica symmetry breaking of some level
to the extent that we can actually
i mean thanks to this pinning trick
and i mean mostly thanks to the spinning
trick
we can actually get a good mathematical
handle on them
so of course it would be interesting to
get
more information still but
sorry but uh it would be
it's it's much nicer in some sense so
if there's any case where we should
actually be able to say interesting
things about algorithms i would think
it's rather in
it's more likely to be in inference
problems than in these csp problems
and even in that case mathematically we
don't understand
the performance of belief propagation
though
yeah if we have time for one more
question may i ask one more
nike it's up to you oh yeah of course
well so as as you're alluding to in
inference problems we know that there is
no uh true replica symmetry breaking
in the in the thermodynamic sense
because of this nishimori
business there is only as the physicists
say dynamical
replica symmetry breaking whereas in
problems that are not
quite inference problems we i guess
even the physicists themselves are not
don't always have a clear opinion about
whether there is merely one step replica
symmetry breaking or perhaps full
replica symmetry breaking like in ksat
at non-zero temperature
my understanding is that there's
supposed to be at some point
full replica symmetry breaking up there
even though
for you know for whatever reason at zero
temperature
k sat um we know that there's only
one step replica symmetry breaking so
since um you know do you have any
sense of the extent to which
uh we might be able to prove that one
step
is enough for
some class of problems which are not
literally
planted problems
yeah i've got no idea to be honest i
guess i'm the wrong person to ask this
question
uh yeah
i mean so another question would be of
course the inference problems
um so maybe that's that's also something
that is a bit
more in the realm of the um
achievable uh in terms of realistic
or reasonable effort would be what
happens if you
[Music]
move away from the base optimal setting
so for example in the stochastic block
model you could ask what happens
if you don't tune
i mean if you if you look at the
boltzmann distribution of
the of the planted model of the
stochastic block model not at
not with this particular beta but with
another beta
right and so so what we would expect is
of course that in one direction you
remain replica symmetric
so if you if you make the temperature
higher you should remain replica
symmetric i suppose
uh or at least that yeah i seem to
remember that conjecture
and this is actually quite interesting
because it's related to another question
which is
um the how correct
inference or how well map should do
right so on the stochastic block model
we would expect
that maybe there's another phase
transition
um where the map starts to
the map starts to kick in
so you might expect that there's again a
regime where
if you do map if you actually find the
most likely
solution that should be orthogonal to
the ground truth or more or less
orthogonal
whereas from another point on that
should be strongly correlated with the
ground truth
so this might be this might be related i
don't know
uh i haven't really thought about it
much but it's
and i don't know if it's if it would be
interesting to anybody but
i mean as a purely actually as a toy
problem it might be
a cute thing to figure out
yeah i guess the related question is i i
don't have a clear understanding of why
zero temperature ksat isn't full replica
symmetry breaking
given that it isn't at zero temperature
it
it probably is full replica symmetry
breaking for large enough alpha
but i mean ksat not not uh oh i see
so the casa threshold itself comes out
as a small rsb
but if you make it denser of course
i see yeah there is a paper by panchenko
i think
link doing interpolation from large
alpha
to infield model right
yeah that's right i see but presumably
there are other constraint satisfaction
problems
where the threshold of satisfiability is
in the rsb regime
yeah for example for a max code
thanks international this hypergraph
coloring i think is the uh
some of the mark scott doesn't have a
threshold for satisfiability maybe i
missed the max cut value i guess
or or also for for uh independent set
for
graphs of lower degree
should also be follow rsp
if we're all still here can i ask
something uh this is related to chris's
comments
so about like whether the physicists
agree whether a certain problem is
one rsvp or full rsb typically so from
what i understand is that you compute
you try to do the rs the one rsv on zats
and you try to see if it's stable or not
towards higher degrees of replica
symmetry breaking
and if it's unstable you just say it's
full replica symmetry break game
i mean it doesn't occur to you that it's
perhaps to rsv or something
like that so there's a dichotomy it
seems that they're in natural problems
there is a dichotomy between one rsb and
full rsv and there is nothing in between
are there any can anybody think of any
natural conditions that one could
can put on a problem to say that's it's
either
one i mean replica symmetric or one rsb
or other than that
it's full rsb it's nothing in between
good question i i don't know the answer
i think there is some example about a
piece bin
a mixed piston model with some
particular mixture
which is some finite level of rsv
yeah it seems yeah are you talking about
some results of
uh tuka and uh probably also
not or i don't remember exactly i don't
recall
who's it is yeah it seemed that the
mixture was very hand-picked it was it
was some very particular
thing but i don't know i don't know how
generic it is this is the point i guess
yeah
any any other questions okay
thanks amin so much for a great talk um
thanks for having me thank you